look I need eggs now I can't make this
new sauce without eggs all right I'm on
it so chop chop on my way Chef wonderful
here Nantucket Island it's a classic we
do this every year now the reason we're
gonna talk is it's time to discuss the
meal we've got a ton of people coming
over how many do you think
too many 80. okay so we're gonna do two
dishes and no Chef on their own can pull
this off so that's why I brought my team
together by the way we worked every year
together hey I'm Kathy Neptune and I
love to cook and I love to make cooking
easy and affordable and healthy and
let's talk about where we got these
lobsters from here I see you're wearing
the 167 raw hat so what we really go out
of our way to get stuff local and fresh
that's what we care about the most and
we all refer to Kathy about some of the
other items but everything's from from
the farm from from the lot from the shop
so we went to 167 raw yesterday local
provider been here forever every every
every year we come down there we go
there and they got us to some of the
nicest Lobsters around they steamed them
for us to save us a little bit of time
let's start with the salad nicoise
okay what do we need we're going to
start out with uh garlic and Dijon
mustard very important Dijon mustard a
red wine vinegar a half of a lemon fresh
parsley that's chopped fresh
um tarragon not the dried the fresh if
you can't find the fresh use half the
amount of dried but fresh is really best
I have to cancel my tour because I
couldn't finish the ERC paperwork in
time guys the ERC money is still
available no way yes way go to
wondertrust.com to learn more keeping
people with their money that's music to
my ears
you need two days to make a salad or
base okay you can't make a Flavor of
Love You can't do it in the same day
okay you could but because it'd just be
too much work so we we already have the
lobster steam we we we we'll go back to
the tape we videotaped there yesterday
from one success
the freshest Seafood on the island those
Club just there we wait in the back
frasers Kathy to pick up that tuna you
talked about very important that was
great how many lobsters do you have here
Eric we've got they gave us nine
nine one and a half pound lobsters now
Lobster's yield point three per pound so
if you've got nine one and a half pound
lobsters nothing to learn point three
pounds per point three per pound most of
it's shell and stuff you can't eat right
right so we have to take them out of the
shell that's going to take a lot of work
we're gonna need four people to do this
for the next hour now are we worried
about the lobster Community are we gonna
get in trouble with the lobsters now
well people get mad about killing
lobsters and so there's a couple
different ways you can get a lobster
ready to eat one way okay uh to prep it
before you boil or steam it okay is to
cut it in the middle of its head and
slice its brain in half okay
that's that's called The Slice the braid
in half and so that's very popular if
you want from the community because
that's the quickest way to kill the
lobster right the second way is the most
uh is most preferred by me is you
actually get you hypnotize the lobster
okay you rub it on the back of its head
and it relaxes okay and you hypnotize it
and it gets into a calm relaxed State
and then you put it into the steam or
boiler the final way which is new is you
give the lobster psychedelic drugs and
so the lobster is very relaxed when it
goes psychedelic drops to the lobsters
so that could be a breakthrough for the
community that so that's where the
Cutting Edge technology is right now and
how to boil a lobster is give it
psychedelic drugs you know you can't
make this stuff up
I'm not making it up I'm just telling
that's the sanest way to say that you're
only going to find this on a chef
wonderful video we're always at The
Cutting Edge if there's a new way to
boil a lobster we're going to find it on
Chef wonderful all right we're going to
be serving today all of these fantastic
Seafoods the lobster and then of course
you want the O'Leary Shard this has won
five Awards and where can you get it
qvc.com and they send the case for free
it's Kevin O'Leary at it's o'leary5lines
at qvc.com before we start our meal
we're going to start with a little let's
call it an aperitif Kathy right
absolutely this is a gazpacho but not
just any English
this is incredible spatula because
gazpachos mean many many many different
things but let's talk about what's
inside this one remember what are we
fast fun and crazy fast fun and fabulous
fast fun and fabulous gazpacho what's in
this Catholic so it's very finely diced
everything cat as celery uh fresh
cucumbers the English style so you don't
have to seed them garlic the sauces oh
and sometimes I put in pepperoncini
which is in here and then also your
sauces cocktail sauce Mexican salsa and
believe it or not ketchup and I use the
base of this Campari tomatoes are we
ready we're going to use what is this
Kathy a regular tortilla chip but make
sure these are chilled you can even
chill the glasses it's even better yeah
wow oh my goodness that smells amazing
May the fork be with you oh May the fork
be with me that's Kathy sing wow Kathy
stealing that okay you saw a route you
saw it pork is going to be with me are
you ready
[Music]
[Applause]
wow did you like it Kevin
look at him and you like the horseradish
little bite in there too horseradish it
kind of builds up and by the second bite
you're feeling the radish
[Music]
what do we have here what's this for
the lobster cob we got our cherry
tomatoes
Farm Fresh here in Nantucket little uh
Pita breads Eric get these homemade pita
breads yep what are we doing here Kathy
fresh
Earth and always Dijon mustard Dijon is
important and what's this going into
what
[Music]
all right I'm on it so Chop Chop on my
way hey how you doing
okay
let's do it
awesome
wow these look great thank you so much
you got it this is what I'm talking
about I only go with the highest quality
tuna and we're at Raw 67 this is where
the very best fish on the island is
look at that look at that check out
check out that is unbelievable look at
the color of that welcome raw 67. I
always come here every year for my swash
salad the tuna and the lobster [__]
legendary Chef one who makes it right
here on the island of the raw material
you'll start here you gotta have the
very best lobster the very best tune-ups
only one place on the island
this is the owner right here are you
kidding she's very nasty but I like it
[Music]
okay Chef Kathy what are we doing here
quick and easy fun fast and fabulous
Tomatoes line them up like this another
plate you can do this way or this way I
like it this way very sharp nice look at
this and then you cut the rest your
knife on the bottom like this
what a trip place it like that
and you're done stop the medicine oh
look at that wow getting ready
but there's lots more meat Eric I just
want to say something as a chef I saw
lots of plums left in the shells I hope
you're not going to waste no we use
everything okay we're gonna make a Bully
game today oh that's very important okay
that's good okay what's the story on the
eggs
we've secured a dozen eggs where are
they
oh there they are that's great
[Music]
Kathy what's this point out what this
stuff is all about fresh herbs we're
doing the dressing for the tuna salad
and I I need some classroom prepared
ahead of time is fresh tarragon and if
you want all the um
quantities you go to Kathy Neptune's
kitchen Shaver's promotion Kathy on
[Music]
that you've put in the microwave the
fresh lemon so you get more juice Dijon
mustard and red wine vinegar gotta have
that okay and oh my goodness stop the
madness is this what we got yesterday
yeah so this is fresh cut and cod tuna
fresh cut in Hot Tuna from 167 raw again
same as promotion but these are our
friends we're gonna do everything in the
bowl except the olive oil cause that's
called our Emulsion ingredient look it
up so these are cherry red wine vinegar
and this is so easy to keep track when
you're busy and visiting with your
people you want to be able to just dump
everything and talk and you'll see
multitasking at its best and most
delicious the bingoes are parsley and
that way you don't miss any of the
ingredients this tarragon and you can
season salt and pepper to taste and look
at how thick it's getting
beautiful beautiful and then of course I
forgot to mention Carlisle oh look at
all the good
if there's any vampires around they
won't be around here today
stop the madness conducting the actual
cooking of the tuna this is incredibly
important because this is the core the
protein of the saladinise the classic
you've seen all the other elements but
now I've got my two assistants let's
start cooking
super hot very very hot because you're
going to sear the tuna you saw that tuna
coming right out of the ocean
this is assistant Dave assistant Tony
very good very good you keep an eye on
its own stage and put it on the plane
this is the kind of work I do every day
okay so now what's happening is Dave is
smoking the tuna even though at a very
high temperature he doesn't want to
overcook it a little pink in the middle
is what we want to do because that is
the classic the swaze the tunity swas
you've got the eggs you've got the
lettuce you've got all the fixings it's
going to be amazing Dave how long before
you look at this again don't screw this
up people are talking
timer two minutes oh you see that he's
using technology for two minutes before
he turns it over good work Dave this is
the kind of talent you're looking for
when I hire guys I want them to
understand Tech very very important
combining the old ways of cooking with
the new ways of Technology brings the
best results all right Dave
look at that
wow you've got the burn mark
The Grille the green eggs
on the Fly decision
that looks perfect
okay ladies and gentlemen after hours
and all the work involved this is a
really a village opportunity and ability
commitment for the Fourth of July two
classic salads every year we gather to
do this it's almost sacred at this point
all fresh ingredients Kathy did an
amazing job Eric you're a beast all the
animals involved are treated humanely on
these dishes okay let's make sure that's
true it is true and so Eric thank Dave
for making the tuna on the go right you
got it just right okay so now Chef
wonderful is here to actually decide is
this a 10 out of 10 or 6.2 or 7 each
year I've got to make this decision I
just take a single piece are you ready
let's start with this it's got some of
the sauce
put it right there oh look at that
uh Anything could happen we don't know
should we try no one's tastes anything
yet it's the honor of Chef one we'll try
this first
the only reason I Mr Wonderful have time
to search for the rare Vermillion
flycatcher is because my companies have
already received money from the employee
retention credit program go to
wondertrust.com to see if your business
qualifies today
[Music]
[Applause]
oh oh
9.64 out of 10 right there and nobody's
even touched that yet let's
oh that's amazing oh hello Larry
cabernetes
where do you get them you'll be saved 14
bucks a bottle ships no charge you don't
love your case
dressing room there are you ready this
is the moment of truth that looks good
enough to you you ready
oh
[Applause]
okay boy okay
another spectacular year
yeah